STRE IR FIRST EVER U.STERVIEW A
>> GREATO
O INVITE Y
TET
SHE PASSED.
WHKEHOASKED TO FORM A GOVERNMENB
HEANIT
SHE GAVEE R OMSHS THE R
S AM
HONOR IS IMMENSE, AND SHH RIBUTO
JU TO NATIONAL LIFE N AIN BUACR
IT WAS A HUGE R.
YOU JUSE ONNE WIT
PRESIDENN AT THE UNITED
NATIME  JOHNSED  QUOTEEPREVBED .
EXCLUSIVE AND DIDN'T REFER
IN THE MTIH PRESEN
BIDEN.
RELATIONSH I IT USED
TOU. I
CR PARTNER OU.K.
RELATIOHIP IS
SPECIAL AND IT'SINGLY T AT A TIE
FANGSS
INEAIV
CHINA.'R FREED LOVINCH ATRG
AND WE ALSO NEEDH
WELL, BECAUSE WE ARE  INCREASEDT
THOSE AUTOCRAT TICK R       S.M
ON BECAUSE WE DO FACE ANAT WE NO
INCR IECWORLD.  ARE PEOPLE IN TN
BELIEF OF THE ECL HAT PREVIOUSM.
KW
WINSTON CHCHL THAT
ERL LATIONSHIP IN  WELL, I APER
TREDOF THE UNITE OF AND IT'S A
M DERMT WE MAKE TH
EVE
SPECIAERHEWORLD.
ONLEESIMES.
I BELIEVE WE'VE EPINOU
UNPRECEDENTED SANCTIONS, LITARY
COMMITTED TH.KWI PUTEN MORE MIL
INE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT HE
REALLYNGAINE AND I
UP AS ANLL T
WHAT IS AN APPALLING WAR C
IN.
>> YOU DA
DEMOCR
PU
ROME INTO
UKRAIN JOIN THE T.
S T BLUFFING
E TALKS ABOUCLAPONS.
'S PRED RE A PRESINTTHE WEST WO
THE REASO BECAUSE SN'TADE A STK
AND T
HE'S BEEN OU THE UKRAI
TO PUSH BACK AGAIN RUSSIAN
RO SHOULT HE DIDT PA OF
S ND BOGUS THREATS
IND  UEON
E TO
THUKISO  THIS NDE MEAG
UKRAINIAN POLAELVES
UL MES
TO OTHER AUTTAIMES
AROUND THE WORLDT SOMEHOW
>> O INVADE -- FOR EXAMPLE TVA.
IT'S SO IMPORTAN
THATE
LUTE. THE SABER
RATTLING THAT WE'RE HEARG FROM
AB CM THE  BACTHE UKRAIAHILLAT'I
WE WNTINUE TSEH AMERICAN ALLIESG
ORPREV'SK ABOUHE
BECAUSE PRESENT BIDEN
UNEQVOCALLY SAID TMO
PLGEHAT WEU.LDEFTAIJUAN IF CHINM
I WAEAR
RETREG DEPY WOG IRST OL TO
BY
ALLI ARLD AND
WE'RE DETERMINED TO WORK WITH O
>> WHEN YOD BY
THAT MEAU WOULD GO AS FA
PRN HAS GONE AND SAY
THE U. WD TAIJUAN
WOULE  DEFEN
INAINVADES?
IMEED TO LEARN THENSFR US THE F
TIN STE UAONIN S OF THE WORLD BK
T BITS AE INDOE PACIFIGININAAVMS
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT DOMESTIC SU.
THE BANKF AN RATES
D SA UBEN
ARE THEY RIGHT?
WHAT IY TRUE IS THS TTERMATTER R
FACING ANLLH OF
SECONDLYINVASION OF S
SHENERGY PRICEWHAT
I'M DE ANISTER IS MA SALL WE CA
ECONOMY ANATACINVESTMENT INTO T
, 'S
I'M FOCUSED
N THATN YOUR GOVERNMEN
UNVE A PROPOSATO RAISERPORATE X
PRNGHE
IN THE U.SKING ADIFFERENT APPRO
EW OEC
MEURYOU'RE TWEETK AND REDOWN E
IT NEVKED.
SAYING HIN           NT BIDE I
SAYS YE RECKLESSLY RUNNINGUP THC
N SO-CALLET
CO
>>ISE OFALL.
E LOWEST OF DEBT
IVIZING BUSINESSESPINGARY ITH L
INSURAX
BECAUSE  WL TER
TO ATTRACT AN INVESTMENT
HARDER TOE
W JOBS ANDE UCCESSAS
WELL.
I WANT TN ECONOMY TO
BE SUCCEFU WELL.
G CRACIES TO S OF THE THINGING
IN THE U.K. IS MOVING FORWARD UR
BUILDINGOADBAND, MOBILE ES AND T
, ASEL
WE NEED  DECIDAX
RATES ARE